We really can't talk about the Overton window
moves and creeping normality in 2019 without
talking about how extreme right wing ideology
has become mainstreamed and is now part of
what is considered legitimate political discourse
in way too many circles.
There's a really good piece in the Guardian
about this by Mark Townsend and machine machinic
ball that spells this out and it's something
I've been telling you for some time now and
I encourage you to read the piece.
The right in the United States has very successfully
pulled the discussion around a ton of political
issues to the right and this is a huge structural
advantage for them because there are too many
issues including abortion, immigration, and
many others.
They are winning merely by pulling the discussion
to the extreme, right?
The left has some wins on this in the United
States.
So over the last two to three years we've
seen the left insert more progressive ideas
into the mainstream discussion about healthcare.
For example, everybody's talking now about
Medicare for all and other single payer systems.
It doesn't mean we're necessarily about to
get them, but the debate has been pulled to
the left on healthcare successfully by the
progressive movement inequality starting with
occupy Wall Street.
And since then with the likes of candidates
like Bernie Sanders and others, inequality
has become mainstreamed as an issue.
Taxation, more progressive ideas on taxation
for example.
But the radicalization that comes from the
right is truly a danger.
I'm going to give you a specific example.
The idea of the great replacement.
Okay.
The great replacement is a right wing nationalist
conspiracy theory that officially started
in France in 2012 by that name.
But there are many versions of it and generally
it's the idea that White Christians are going
to be replaced by non European people, Brown
people in many cases, sometimes not Christians.
And it's going to destroy everything and it's
going to be terrible.
And there are versions of this that date back
decades, hundreds of years, even longer.
Uh, maybe, uh, I guess I'd have to think about
it without being called the great replacement,
but the idea has been around for a long time.
This fear of the other, the other is going
to come in and replace us and take our status
in society and maybe take our a riches or
maybe take our women, right?
I mean there's different versions of this
great replacement idea, but it has been used
to stoke nationalist extremist ideas and it's
been around for a long time here in the United
States.
White nationalists and other right wingers
have been pushing this for years in relation
specifically to immigration policy.
And usually it relates to Latin American immigrants
and it has unfortunately become mainstream.
They've succeeded at this.
It's on Fox News all the time.
It's not fringe websites that are talking
about this.
It has infected what is considered mainstream,
right wing political thinking.
Fox News host, Laura Ingram did a segment
in August, which we covered basically a sanitized,
great replacement segment about legal and
illegal immigrants forcing demographic change
in the United States and destroying the country
by doing it.
Tucker Carlson on Fox News, very similar thing,
numerous segments.
One in which he said that Brown people coming
to the United States legally becoming citizens
and voting in elections is a form of election
hacking.
This is a fundamentally, it's a replacement
sort of conspiracy theory.
Another segment in which Tucker Carlson ranted
about immigrants making our country dirtier.
This type of discussion at one point was not
considered serious conversation on these issues.
I still would have disagreed with what the
right thought at the time, but they were not
overtly radical in this particular way that
I'm showing you.
The Institute for Strategic Dialogue has been
studying this and they found that these formerly
sort of obscure ideas are now everywhere.
Donald Trump references them in speeches on
Twitter.
It's happening in European countries among
the nationalist parties.
It's all over social media, particularly on
Twitter, even outside of the president's own
tweets.
The right likes to say that there's left wing
bias just implicit in all of our discussions
and on media and they love the example of
Twitter is left wing because if you miss gender,
people on purpose you could get banned.
This is a joke compared to the reality that
straight up xenophobic, almost friend knowledgist
type trash.
Look that up.
If you don't remember what that is is now
part of the discussion around many of these
issues.
They have slick branding.
They come up with wording that makes it sound
relatively innocuous if you're not paying
close enough attention, but they are pushing
extreme ideas into the gray area of valid
political discussion and it has the effect
that is beneficial for them of pulling the
Overton window seriously to the right, the
right slick.
A branding has pushed extreme right wing ideas
into mainstream discourse.
They've successfully integrated them into
even corporate media discussions of many political
issues while at the same time continuing to
shout that there's inherent left wing bias
in all media and social platforms.
This is one of the most successful disinformation
campaigns of the last 30 years and what we
all need to understand is that even if the
craziest ideas that they espouse aren't made
into reality, they're not made into policy.
It makes the marginally less crazy.
Ideas seem middle of the road in comparison.
And that's the danger of the mainstreaming
of extremist nationalists, right wing ideas
of the Overton window being pushed to the
right and if the creeping normalization that
we've experienced over the last 15 years,
but particularly over the last year,
two and a half under Donald Trump.
I want to hear from you about this.
Do you agree with my assessment and how do
you think we fight it?
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
Please follow me there.
Uh, and follow the David Pakman show on Twitter
as well.